[Music]
all right uh walter you're gonna be very
excited okay balenciaga has got some new
shoes for sale only twenty seven hundred
bucks
[Music]
are they just all socks now for these
i'm gonna wait for the i'm gonna wait
till the friends and family sale
i don't know if you can wait that long
when you see these puppies
wow
2700 dineros are those just trashed
chucks yeah that's like their whole use
you
this is couture we're looking at this is
like zombie apocalypse shoes
you know that's really how they look by
the way yeah i kind of love how ballsy
the designers are though they're just
like watch working ballsy or trolly are
those gonna fall apart like in two days
or it just looks like it is uh it'll
take twenty seven hundred dollars to
find out
sounds like a good business yeah yeah
let's do it
oh shoot shall we go in on these
together that's why i wanna see what
like get them in hand and see if they're
actually like
worn and like it's actually dirt or if
it's like paint
and constructed yeah
what do you think it has to be
replicated no i like when i see those i
literally think of like those those what
my shoes would look like during the
zombie apocalypse these look like
frank's shoes to me yeah
like after yeah that's like some world
war ii shoes she wouldn't have written
ballanciaga i think she would have
written um help help me these look like
shoes that should be highlighted in red
in schindler's list
why would the shoes be highlighted
because only the club remember there's
one moment in schindler's where the the
girls wearing red
i don't know but like doesn't it i don't
mind
are those like uh
like the talk of the town because
they're like holy [ __ ] 2 700. right are
there people that are supporting it like
oh yeah i feel like valencia that's how
much it goes for because it's like it
almost seems like in high fashion when
you talk down on it then you're the one
that doesn't get it yeah you're too too
scared to disagree well this one's
beyond you then yeah no because the
other bellanciaga is you know you you
see them you know you may not like them
but you're like okay whatever someone's
gonna pay for but like these if i saw
these i'd be like dude you're you're
[ __ ] i like their bags their bags look
cool you're a [ __ ] dude i like how they
say that yeah i wouldn't buy it because
i can't afford it but i think their bags
are pretty sick yeah they like their
bags i like some of the stuff that they
got at the store it looks like well it
looks like you have to wear the whole
outfit though yeah you can't just have
that and then like wear like hawaii
clothes they come in low top as well oh
cause that's okay that's those look like
[ __ ] these are good these are okay is
there no [ __ ] heel to that
or is it just stepped in yeah yeah
these are made from corrosion yeah you
know like you just put your you just put
your foot in you know nike maybe you get
some [ __ ] crocs dude
what do you say dude
rocks like those are sliding like i'm
sorry i didn't know you were a doctor
i wear scrubs sometimes too
i never wore a pair of like crocs like i
didn't i think i need to get something
honestly it's a game changer dude
dude but if you get them now they're
gonna be like um you're like five years
ten years behind
not for fashion
it's comfortable
i see if i'm not behind fine i'll just
go bare but it's uncomfortable to be
fashionably late
yeah like okay let's be honest though
like i'm a nike fanboy if nike put a
swoosh on there would i get him would
you would you
do it you'd have to huh i probably would
get it just to like put it on display oh
it's like a dislike what i wear collect
shoes i used to work wait what's the
most expensive shoe you ever owned shoe
probably like value-wise okay
and like when i got them people were
like dude how'd you get those because at
the time i think immediately after they
were selling for 1500 2 000 immediately
after they're probably way crazier now
yeah now i don't know how much there but
like
i got them off the nike app
so what happened was they released them
and online online their site crashed i
don't think nike expected this
foolishly they didn't expect this many
people wanting to get the shoe
so
people on twitter i see it in my box but
i can't go through with the sale i'm
like and this is after an hour it was
really really they call it like getting
cart jacked or something something like
yeah it's in their cart but they
couldn't hit check out fast yeah no one
could no one could hit check no one
could do it so no one's getting it and
then it's those yeah it's those
so i what i did was after an hour i was
like you know what i'm just going to
check um the mobile site because at the
time mobile sites were different so i
checked the mobile site and sure enough
in my cart were two pairs because i hit
by
buy twice but you can't buy two so it
came back you can only buy one um if i
rushed you know i cancelled one and then
my sale went through nice wow i just
fortunately even after an hour later
because no one was able to buy it
because cause everyone's on the site the
what the main site crack crap are they
like in a gas a glass case at home or no
so i actually i when i got shoes i wore
all of them i wore them but my feet grew
oh really yeah like and yes to answer
your questions
everything else grew everything else
grew too yeah
like a waistline yeah or was the size
sacrificing a different appendage like
like now i can't touch my thumb and my
middle finger anymore
oh wow you know what i mean like lucky
yeah
then he can't he can't do that anymore
because his dick's so big oh
oh i thought you meant like this way oh
no
you're just so fat you can't touch your
pants
that's only that's only during special
time that's when you're in a special
time that's only when my torso comes
over
no but my feet grew and this i can't
wear them anymore i wore them one time
and you know when you get those um blood
blisters on the on your heel
i was getting those
and so i can't wear them anymore but
though like i'm trying to i'm probably
gonna sell my shoes at one point but
like those are you don't want to just
hold it for like another five ten years
oh i'll keep i'm gonna keep those i'm
gonna keep them like 5 000 bucks yeah
but you know the bad thing with nike
though i don't remember if the tiffany
has it but if you have white like that
bottom part of the yellows right yeah
yellows and yellow take it in for laser
lighting at the ortho that's true that's
true
just over time not even wearing them it
turns yellow and actually if you don't
wear them it it hardens the rubber even
though it just disintegrates like all
that stuff that they have like vacuum
packed or whatever they like take it out
and it falls apart plastic wrap them i
know i guess you've seen the new nike
high tops where they don't completely
sew the top of the tongue and it's just
exposed and it looks broken yeah why
they do that oh the ones that's yellow
it's the ones the high tops everyone's
wearing now right yeah it's got the foam
and i'm like
that [ __ ] looks unfinished they even
have nike has one now you just slip your
shoes you just slip your foot in
like
i think i know what you're talking about
one of those made for like uh it was
like for disabled people
it might be yeah
because i remember tj was saying that
they they came out with those for like
disabled people put all the sneaker
heads bottom up yeah like anthony after
they bought it so uh people actually
they don't have it i'm selling them now
yeah way higher price meantime anthony
has like every size
he bought them so just so people
wouldn't get them yeah i don't even know
i don't even know anthony but i feel
like that's something he would do
how did you do that
he's all like they don't need to go out
how are they gonna get out of the house
he's like why would they need to go out
of the house they ain't got the whole
fit to match
i can't let these shoes go to waste bro
he bought it for all the kendra's yo
yeah i think these are what was your
guys's most expensive shoe that you ever
bought
price wise uh most expensive shoe
mine was close to 300-ish for red wings
but that's it's life time [ __ ] some
work boots i think i think a long time
ago i may have accidentally bought some
limited edition supras remember when
supras were super yeah
cause like to fit in your osiris
collection yeah when i was traveling you
know like you just don't know what's
what and i just like didn't look at the
exchange rate and i accidentally bought
these really expensive ones and i was
like oh [ __ ] and i would just wear them
to do dance shows and then sneaker has
to go bro how dare you dance in those i
was like in what and then i looked it up
and i was like oh [ __ ] i've been [ __ ]
these up
you didn't know when the price tag was
high you're that ballin this is why he's
a 10 million dollar man i'm just that
bad at math for exchange rates
but what did you look at your car charge
and you're just like oh my god i spent a
thousand dollars on shoes yeah i mean i
did buy well after it was after the fact
i also bought some like limited italian
denim adidas jumpsuit which i was like
why would i spend that much on that [ __ ]
denim adidas jump [ __ ] lame but the man
yeah i'm like who am i trying to be a
freaking mob boss in glendale
but i feel like you still pull it off
you know
especially
i gave it away because i was too shamed
really
who did you give it to me
from my homie and my crew
yeah was it it's this adidas italian
like denim it looks like you know the
adidas jumpsuits how they look like the
ones that the armenians have yeah but it
was just all denim oh so that sounds
kind of cool like an armenian canadian
shield yeah
i was embarrassed i bought it
it's hard for me to spend too much on my
shoes cause i know they're gonna go on
my feet and i'm stomping around and i'm
gonna scuff them up so hard dress shoes
probably my most expensive i do have one
pair of expensive dress shoes dress
shoes they even count though because
that's like buying a tuxedo right
they're supposed to be though right yeah
we fancy
cause the sneakers you know i i don't i
won't go on ebay and pay like 500 for
one i'll just go on like if i don't get
it now at this point in my life if i
don't get it from the app i don't
whatever what's your buy it now or
what's your price for those tiffany's if
someone wanted to buy them off you
what's your let go price
i don't i've even thought about it
because i i don't i don't plan on
letting them go but like i don't know if
someone goes i'll give you 500 bucks or
a thousand bucks whatever i'll probably
consider it i don't know that i would
how much did you get it for 160. what
was it
but then they you said a week later they
were selling it for two grand and you
still didn't let it go week later it was
like the the day like the day and you
still didn't sell it for 2000 wow
because you know i wanted the tiffany i
don't like high tops too much i have a
lot of high tops but i don't like it i
like low tops better when the tiffany
low top came out i was at an auction and
your guys are sitting in vegas the guys
didn't know how to run an auction
because you have to have a minimum bid
amount they just people were going like
100 100 and 25 cents
hundred dollars and fifty cents and then
so i just went i just went like uh 180.
oh come on man and then like 180 and a
quarter
and then and then i was like dude and
then so i just said you know i just said
two two hundred you come up i don't have
a lot of money i go i don't know 200 and
a quarter
at that point is when i i told myself
i'm not going to buy them i don't care
i'm not going to buy them so i went 210
210 and a quarter 220
and he's like come on with two
and i'm like come on 225 225 a quarter
okay you can have him
nice at a circle i was like i'm not
gonna get him i'm gonna just [ __ ] them
yeah because he's supposed to he's
supposed to do you gotta do either five
dollar ten dollar increments you can't
do a quarter but they didn't they had
never run an auction before because at
this point in nike sb history
this one was the one that was the most
wanted
after the fact the heineken dunk was one
of the most wanted dunks but that was
after the fact because no one really no
one really knew okay but when the
tiffany dunk was out
that's when i was oh i got i gotta get
these i gotta get these and then my my
source
he didn't get them they need like their
their store didn't get him so and i was
i happened to be in vegas and i found
out that they're doing an auction so oh
go so i didn't get those and so i was
like okay
i gotta get the high tops so it has some
kind of sentimental thing oh i see that
but yeah but like if if someone did
offer like a good amount of jeez or
something yeah she's i'd be like i i
would be like ah how about two g's in a
quarter
you